In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxanian for June 7th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Theldotus of Ankara.
On the 7th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Martyr Theldotus
of Ankara.
A Christian of Ankara in Galatia, Saint Theldotus, had been brought up in Piety by the Holy
Virgin and Marjorie, Acusa.
Being married, he worked honestly as a tavernkeeper, and made use of every opportunity to practice
charity to all, impartially, Christians and infidels like, to such a degree that God gave
him the grace to perform many miraculous healings.
When under the direction of the governor, Theldteknon, persecution raged in Ankara in 303 or
311, Theldotus turned his inn into a refuge where Christians could find food that had
not been offered to idols.
In peril of his life, he visited the confessors in prison to encourage them not to weaken
and buried the bodies of the martyrs.
By this means he was able to encourage his friend, Victor, to martyrdom, when the persecutors
were attempting to overcome his resolution with false promises.
Filled with new courage, Victor patiently suffered the torture, but gave way at the last
moment, so that at the end of the contest, he asked to reflect on the propositions they had
made him.
Returned to prison, he died of his wounds, deprived of the crown of victory.
After Christian called valence, having resisted to death, Theldtus gathered his relics, which
had been thrown into the river Halleys, and went to bury them in the town of Malos.
There he met a group of Christians whom he had earlier freed from prison.
In the joy of finding one another again, they decided to share a fraternal meal and invited
fronton, the priest of Malos, to join them.
After the meal, Theldtus advised fronton to build a chapel in that peaceful place to house
the relics of the martyrs, and giving him his ring as a pledge, promised to obtain holy
relics for him.
On his return to Ankara, Theldtus found the town in great confusion after the arrest of
Byzanthe Acusa and her six companions.
He remained in hiding with other Christians and prayed for the confirmation of the saints
in their trials.
As soon as he heard that they had died by drowning without having denied the Lord, he gave
thanks to God and turned his lamentation to tears of joy.
Having learned the details of their sufferings, he mused over some way of tricking the guards'
valence to get possession of the saints' bodies and give them Christian burial.
Saint Acusa appeared to him while he was at prayer, reminding him of the care she had taken
to teach him to live according to the gospel, and advised him to go quickly and fearlessly
to carry out his God-pleasing mission.
Shrouding himself in the darkness of night when a terrible storm had arisen, Theldtus and
his companions reached the lakeside.
The guards there, frightened by the apparition of the holy martyr, Sosander, armed and surrounded
by flames, fled in terror and the water, disturbed by the storm, gave up the bodies of the saints.
They were thus able to gather them and give them devout burial in a church known only to themselves.
The next morning, the whole town was in turmoil, unlearning of the removal of the holy
martyr's bodies.
On the governor's orders, the soldiers arrested all the Christians they came across to
put them to questioning.
Policronion, one of Theldtus' companions, was arrested and losing courage under the torture
revealed where the bodies had been buried and denounced Theldtus as the one responsible
for the enterprise.
Death to his friends pleased that he flee, Theldtus went to hand himself over to the governor,
confiding himself to the power of the life-giving cross.
When he went to the interrogation hall, he looked with a smile at the fire and at the instruments
of torture and rejecting Theldteknon's proposals with scorn, derided the weakness of a religion
that needed so many armed men against a single soldier of Jesus Christ.
His words, through the governor and the pagan priestesses who tore their hair and rent
their clothes, into a great fury, and the crowd cried out that the enemy of the gods was
being punished.
After having had him beaten, the tyrant had the martyr laid on the gridiron and gave the
executioners leave to tear his flesh with iron nails.
They then poured vinegar on his wounds and touched them with flaming torches, armed with supernatural
endurance by the invocation of the name of Christ.
The saint replied to his torturers that these sufferings, far from overcoming him, gave him striking
proof of the strength that God gives to those who love him.
They broke his teeth and jaw with stones.
Then the torturers, being exhausted, he was thrown into prison.
Five days later, he was taken before the tribunal again and subjected to the same torturers,
after which they laid him on red-hot bricks.
As the torture remained ineffective and moreover exposed the magistrate to ridicule, felt
that none ordered that he be beheaded and his body thrown into the fire.
Arriving at the scaffold, the auditors gave thanks to God and prayed that he put an end
to the persecution and give peace to his church.
When turning towards the Christians who were present, he exorted them to dry their tears
and thanked the Lord for having given it to him to finish his battle with happiness.
He received with joy the sword cut that was to gain him the eternal crown.
The pyre on which they placed his body was suddenly surrounded by a light so dazzling that
the executioners could not get near to feed the fire and the body remained undamaged.
That same day, Franton, the priest from Malos, arrived in town with a donkey bearing wine.
The animal stopped in exhaustion near the place where the body of Saint Thodotus was being
guarded by the soldiers.
Franton by the ladder to spend the night with them Franton learned what had happened, offered
that they try his wine and having got them drunk, removed the body of the holy martyr, put
on its finger the ring that the saint had earlier given him and heaved it onto his donkey.
Guided by an angel, the beast went straight to the place that Thodotus had indicated to Franton
for the building of a church, and thus it was that he kept his promise to house his relics.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.